hi I'm Mike Green I write music for TV
shows coming up next much much more when
lifestyles return repair for the most
advanced hot wheels ever
[Music]
science rules the TV show you're
probably here for is the Bill Nye the
Science Guy theme
[Music]
how did I get into this business I came
to Los Angeles to be a rock star
I did not become a rock star I learned
the recording business so I started
doing a lot of songwriting producing a
lot of records David Bowie Cypress Hill
hit Frost
Ice Cube and I also started getting TV
stuff I wound up doing tons of Barbie
commercials hot wheels commercials
there's Oprah dr. oz lifestyles of rich
and famous lots of different shows when
I got hired to do the Bill Nye the
Science Guy theme song they said we
don't want it to sound like a kids show
[Music]
the theme song that I did which is kind
of this hip-hop thing it may not sound
like it's groundbreaking today but at
that time it was pretty bold of them to
go with a song like that
the beat is not tempo hip-hop beat and a
number of the things like a bill bill
bill bill it's basically if you listen
to jump around jump jump jump jump there
was one day here at the studio where we
had a bunch of rappers I asked them you
know what go into there and yell bill
bill bill bill I don't even remember who
was there could have been alt be real
the cypressville might have been there
kid frost might have been there Ralph M
look [ __ ] dubious might have been there
I can't remember that's how the song
goes
for the Bill Nye the Science Guy I want
to bring in real singers because that
was me singing that I sent those and I
said why are the voices different right
here I said well because I wanted to put
in real singers I mean this the original
version that's just me that's a scratch
track no put your voice back on there
it's funnier I give bill a lot of credit
he wanted kids to learn about science
and he wanted them to love science not
for the splashy elements of it but just
because the actual knowledge of science
is cool I feel really lucky that I was
involved
[Music]
you